it does mark the unofficial start to
summer so
uh in that regard registered dietitian
mia sin shares a nutritious alfresco
dining menu to enjoy
outdoors as the weather heats up not
quite barbecue
hey las vegas now happy unofficial start
to summer i have the ultimate better for
you all fresco dining menu that's easy
to make
and nutritious starting with appetizers
these mozzarella bites and sweet onion
petals by farmridge are ready in minutes
simply pop these mozzarella bites in the
microwave for 50 seconds or in the oven
for a melt-in-your-mouth appetizer made
with 100
real mozzarella cheese so they're a good
source of protein and calcium
these crispy sweet onion petals make a
great burger topping and
are ready to eat after 10 minutes in the
oven they also come with an
aussie style dipping sauce buy them in
the freezer aisle of albertson's bonds
walmart and more just check the product
locator at farmridge.com
now another easy appetizer that can help
you meet your recommended
three plus servings of veggies for the
day is my veggie dip cups
i paired sliced veggies with the new
creamy fresh cravings hummus which
offers a balanced mix of good fats fiber
and plant protein from chilean extra
virgin olive oil non-gmo chickpeas
and savory tahini it comes in different
flavors including classic and roasted
red bell pepper
another nutritious dip to pair with
sliced veggies and tortilla chips
is my single serve seven layer dip start
with beans and top with guacamole
sour cream or plain greek yogurt fresh
cravings refrigerated salsa
cheese and green onion salsa is
classified as a veggie by the usda
and like the fresh cravings hummus the
refrigerated salsa is made with a short
list of whole food ingredients
find both the fresh cravings salsa and
hummus in the produce section at smith's
next an all fresco dining menu is
incomplete without burgers
these new cauliflower veggie burgers by
dr prager's are packed with six
different vegetables and feature the
same veggie forward look and flavor
profile that dr praker's customers know
and love
dr prager's products make it easy and
convenient for the whole family to enjoy
vegetable packed meals made with clean
nourishing ingredients
find them at whole foods nationwide in
the freezer section
then finally i have a festive dessert
with benefits made with only four
ingredients
these oat cups are packed with filling
fiber and are naturally sweetened with
fruit to a large mixing bowl combine two
cups of quick oats and two large ripe
bananas press the mixture into a
pre-greased muffin pan and bake for 10
minutes at 350 degrees fahrenheit or
until set
fill your oat cups with plain or vanilla
yogurt and top with berries
i hope you enjoyed all of these recipes
and tips you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas
and nutrition tips daily